born in New York City it was and then
you what you moved to Texas Dallas Texas
when I was a baby
yeah did you like this in this herd of
Delta yeah did you like did you like it
in Texas I did not sorry look that guy
went whoo and now he's hearing right
there
I totally alienated them yeah all right
I didn't enjoy it I I I didn't really
enjoy Dallas and one of the things I
didn't like about it was Dallas there
are no basements in Dallas and so I
would go other places when I was a kid
like I would go to Cleveland and in
Cleveland people have basements and they
like finish them out and they turn them
into like fancy like theater rooms or
like workout play ping pong or whatever
yeah you can't do that in Dallas so my
main complaint with Dallas was no
basements so you actually you actually
grew up thinking I wish I could live in
Cleveland yes yeah I loved Cleveland
yeah I was like oh this is the city for
me yeah this place Cal town yeah please
Oh Cleveland the big stuff with that
what about New York New York's got to be
incredibly fantastic for you yeah well
there are a lot of basements which is
nice you've got to get a criteria other
than basement well here's the thing I
will say that's a tough thing now as an
adult man who's single it's very
difficult for me to go look for an
apartment and be like what's your
basement situation like I've got some
stuff I gotta do ya hear yelling from
inside the apartment hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please